all right so I've been testing the new
OnePlus pad for about two weeks now this
is a 480 Android tablet so there are a
lot of Android tablets out there with
interesting features this is one of them
but it also feels like if you really
want to make it you have to pull people
away from the iPad and so they thought
about that too so this one has an 11.5
inch display with a unique seven by five
aspect ratio and it's 144 Hertz refresh
rate there's also an optional keyboard
case that's 150 bucks after the
pre-order window and it connects with
magnets and pins and it has a nice color
matching keyboard and trackpad and the
trackpad does have this nice hovering
cursor feature which we've seen that
before the pen is a nice responsive
OnePlus Stylo with a pressure sensitive
tip and a flat size so it doesn't roll
away when it's on a table and it charges
just by magnetically popping it onto
that top edge with this neat little
animation that we've also seen before
the demensity 9000 chip is solid the
build quality is metal the webcam is in
the correct spot on the long side and
the camera on the back doesn't suck plus
it has a 9 500 milliamp hour battery and
67 watt fast charging well played one
plus